hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to outlast - we're on
our way to see Papa naught but I think
we're gonna be moving through some
heretic territory because it can't just
be this house maybe it is hello who's
there
Chris Traeger from out last one okay no
nevermind goodbye I was a mr. stupid
alright so we got to get down there oh
this seems about a good path as any why
not why not do that why not do that that
might be an element oh really
there through your incredible deductive
reasoning you've deduced that there is
an elevator right here can I do this
generators yeah they must they seem so
technologically advanced also is a good
way to start up an episode just
screaming from the distance of a pain to
death oh hi oh my god
it is joyous ah so we are the stars of a
travailing woman mm-hm
place to break it 488 can you just Yelp
it
mm-hm
okay you keep rambling about whatever
you're rambling about now I'm going to
carry on with what I'm doing which is
very important work such that I get my
wife back there's nothing here but
potatoes ah
I don't need potatoes they need a way
out all great of course Oh probably
coming back that way a long time from
now so now where are you all right you
know what I'm just going to go for it
okay so I don't know where to go but
there's got to be a generator around
here somewhere
they're not going to show me that I'm
just gonna have to find it on my own why
is there dead people everywhere there
can't be this many people to kill it
just can't be right
there's that body right there go through
okay oh good
why why some us dead why so many dead
bodies every all that creepy that's
[ __ ] creepy okay fine then let's go
hello
found you there's an easter egg or
something oh boy
now as I behold the living creature
God's limitation fresh in my mind I
asked are you the fourth strange
creatures reveal didn't kill and the
voice came from the firmament that has
over their hand said unto me son of man
and saith the Lord you shall be Ezekiel
to these wretched times and Muhammed to
its chosen people and Noah to the flood
of blood in flame that will destroy the
heathens and Gentiles and Pharisees and
like the for creatures of Ezekiel and of
John and of Isaiah and of Daniel behold
a wheel there upon the earth by the
living creatures thousands of eyes and
none of them human but black an
intelligent and silent like the eyes of
beasts ready for slaughter and where the
unfazed creatures looked the eyes of the
Rings focused for the spirit of the
creatures was in the wheels and a spirit
of the wheels was in the crew
what are you getting better not not bad
not bad getting closer to it I need to
hear Papa not a bit more before I become
fully indoctrinated yeah this was
definitely fun good to know that I'm
finding all the secret Easter egg pieces
of his literary proficiency high level
only ecstasy the Lord anthems designer
found off and all debts to God come do
oh my god wailing there's pain
there's blood but it is joy at all
okay the children of town pretty much
okay you keep looking at me why are you
looking at me okay in a crimson bra Rio
Grande
oh boy oh boy it's weird
I'd rather not revel in that ecstasy oh
she's just repeating yourself over and
over you're standing there in the middle
of the road well [ __ ] I'm here now oh
okay all right then I don't think this
bedroom of children really deserve this
but seems like all their children are
dead so cults gonna die out soon enough
I guess okay so this must be the place
it seems to be the end of the law oh no
there's more okay I just gotta follow
the line let's see what I got to do okay
all right you keep rambling there you
keep having a fun time I'm high heretic
you see oh hi parents if you think
that's not me oh boy oh this ain't good
I oh god no oh yeah you
I'm going oh it's a dead end yeah
working as always on the flesh and quite
as well do that I'll [ __ ] goddammit
slam the goddamn door on them where do I
go where do we go ah [ __ ]
slam the door [ __ ] you okay gotta go
gotta go oh I don't know where I'm going
can't see [ __ ] can't see [ __ ] oh well
that ain't good
okay alright seems like they man
stupidly lost me like a bunch of idiots
even though I was a bit of an idiot to
being caught by them to be half caught
by them but they led me right here The
Fool simian I need to talk to you and
deke a secret because if you're knowing
the unsure errs and such and medicines I
hope you know I do not trade any more
words and strictly needful when we make
the trip in the Damned world for
gasoline and electricals and other such
necessaries as we can make I've got
something friendly with the publican boy
who sells us the pills Papa needs and
when I mentioned them and study AIDS the
boy laughed and said a body didn't need
penicillin for studying unless a body
with studying - have you heard of such
things I do not want to ask Papa for
fear of I don't know what but I do not
want to accidentally poison him neither
please come see me ah okay
so it's a slightly not so intelligent
person going into town so they did have
to integrate with the real world the
real world to get supplies for gasoline
an idea I can find my way back to jail
in there somehow
what didn't seem - here we go
what Maggie's gone without firing it up
all night [ __ ] hi hi okay right thank
you
I just fixed your generator for you
ma'am
how happy are you oh you're reveling in
the ecstasy of the Lord I see ah good my
favorite choice of revelry man your
animations are a bit stiff and that's
what makes you slightly more
disconcerting than if you weren't that
okay all right okay you keep doing that
oh boy they locked me in here good one
blood champagne I'm gonna go this way
oh I just went in a big goddamn circle
oh that's what I do all right then I'm
gonna go - ow [ __ ] I'm gonna go down
this way I'm not going to hide in there
that's for damn sure
Oh
hold on I heard someone screaming but
now no and screaming no more is they
dead
were you not dead okay well lock they
got smart they listen to poppin off and
they lock their damn doors well I'm just
going to make my way back because I'm
tall I don't want to be forgiven I don't
want to be forgiven I don't wanna be
forgiven I don't want to be forgiven I
don't wanna be forgiven I don't wanna be
forgiven I don't want to be forgiven I
don't want to be forgiven I don't want
to be forgiven oh no no no no no I'm
gonna hide the barrel can the tourists
stop screaming please just a little pad
I don't even know if she was chasing me
in the first place but it seemed like it
where she she is very she hope kind of
got it right there that's where she is
okay
but maybe I can go in this way no I am
hath sent me unto you learn grammar lady
oh boy
better not be down here there's nothing
down here anyway this is a place to get
lost and then die you're down there
nothing you didn't see nothing Wow okay
I'm in trouble I'm in trouble come on
just looking what are you doing so why
are you filling your Chloe you're stuck
on I didn't make any go [ __ ] come on
what was they stuck on and we stuck on
nothing we still got a whole lot of
nothing I'll start on dick and dirt look
oh boy
alright I'm a rush service because I've
been taking the long way around huh
by [ __ ] wife what to do that you're
fine you're peaceful you were a lovely
person the [ __ ] huh I don't know what
the [ __ ] is happening here she's up
there and I'm trying to get by okay
there's my chance I'm just gonna go for
it oh I am hooking it I am buggered
flying okay go go go
are you okay you're gonna be ravenous in
your pen and clear you get a penance
yourself are you gonna penance someone
like me I don't know if I deserve all
this penance I don't know if I deserve
it at all alrighty then
yeesh ye see you see okay where am I now
what did I say
temple gained established 1971 founded
by sullivan north of the modern Ezequiel
their knives sharp for the enemy
it felt inevitable like a dream or a
memory but not mine okay then all right
he found it in 71 that means naught is a
bit old now he's getting up in years
I didn't look in the well I shouldn't
look in that well well I vaguely
remember this now I don't recall the
well being like that yes please what
please wipe I didn't let nothing happen
what am I let happen okay good I'm back
here oh I know we're not alone here I'm
not even alone inside my own mind
everything is getting all kinds of
messed up oh I know how this one goes I
okay alright let's just let's just get
this over with
hi cuz I think we all know where oh
that's that award-winning song principle
value alright here we go again
ooh boy oh wait oh music box oh hello
Halen I'm bored mr. cohen's still
talking about shut up play up nice and
tall
oh boy justice yeah it's weird how we're
in Jessica's locker and it's Jessica's
huh
you're going to be a jack-in-the-box
better not be a jack-in-the-box why am I
doing this why did I do that that's like
a horror movie 101 you never crank the
music box that there because that leads
to death oh boy oh boy that was a bad
idea to do that oh okay oh I'm gonna go
here first what's in here I don't care
stop screaming I think I got [ __ ] to do
a lot of [ __ ] to do I've been making a
lot of errors and I need these bandages
I need a bag all right
oh hello what are you oh so I was kinda
right oh maybe not
I remember you oh hey come by alrighty
then
can you get out oh well this don't seem
good Oh
in New York okay all right man thank you
run now I vaguely remember that well
bamm-bamm that real good I was gonna BAM
it so good like you never knew you could
all right here we go
run run run whoo hello all right why so
many dead I don't think you have any
congregations that keep killing oh no oh
no I gotta lock that
I gotta lock it yeah no don't open and
lock in a kid okay I locked we'll never
be able to get in now now they have no
way
there is no way of God what do I do
about this how am I supposed to be able
to look that one's jammed there's no
window that I can climb through is there
oh this one no down here okay got it
just in time too he did not see a thing
yeah whatever
keep talking to the darkness I'm down
there winning all right no no where's
it's gonna go but hopefully it can give
me anything
oh hi okay alright then I'm assuming you
can't do anything to me so I'm just
gonna get oh whoa whoa whoa oh God Oh
what the [ __ ] he was coming in after me
I didn't realize it I couldn't see it
was a cloak blackfish here okay here we
go again I guess uh not BAM
little moderate damage all right but now
at least I know where to go
I'm just gonna go I'm not even gonna
waste any time now you know it standing
time I'm just gonna go for it it's gonna
be awesome and I'm gonna gun it fast as
I can
round down here and if I just go for it
maybe he can't get to me in time and
I'll be alive and not dad don't do it no
no no no no no you don't Oh ah okay all
right how's this folks John it who did
fund
who'da thunk who'da thunk that was what
I was going for I didn't Punk that Jesus
frickin [ __ ] what is that all too
well
oh is that the same well that I just
fell into and for some reason that is
actually logical and actually happened I
don't know what's in here but I'm going
in here
lock that oh it's got no lock on it oh
boy oh boy did their bed or something
tom Oh fire
wait turn the flash [ __ ] well let the
bows that burned I don't want to do that
whoa - the bloody City whoa did the
bloody City huh oh hi
okay yeah um it seems unsafe it seems
bad they're they're kind of everywhere
if I can go whoa okay don't go through
that one oh boy
can I hide under arrest no oh no no no
no no no you don't know that you don't
know that you don't know anything about
consuming the flesh yes no idea he has
no idea I am too smart for his kind
around here oh hell yeah oh hell no L
know L know L know
hell yeah can you bring look okay I
think we're good on the closet on the
closet
good old amnesia style I'm the closet
don't worry about a thing
they will go away and I will be just
fine that is how this usually goes and I
am NOT going to prepare myself by going
outside of this goddamn box if you even
think for a second that I'm gonna cry
out there and face whatever monstrosity
ZAR fighting me no no no no no no I am
NOT and I will not I will never do that
no no no no no no no hey what the [ __ ]
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god Oh
clock me holy [ __ ] oh my god am i
dying
oh he's gone bad oh you definitely saw
that
season this Christ will not leave me
alone okay I'm assuming that was him
running the other way which is good I
think go go go go go go come on come on
what are you doing what do you you gotta
be kidding me this way no no no no come
on just hmm
just come on okay go go go go go go go
okay okay okay okay we're good we're
good we're good this looks dark and
scary and spooky oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh boy okay okay we're fine were you
who are you why are you here I'm just
gonna sit here and record you for a
while because this is normal human
behavior and no gain I'm done okay cool
you just carry on carry on poor thing
okay I don't know why they got her down
here but I'm assuming that some part of
the process of getting rid of the
Antichrist is uh couraging is not a good
way I don't know what I [ __ ] Oh God
Oh oh-oh-oh I'm not gonna zoom in on
that oh well here we got one quick one
Oh God
all right then no zooms no Jim okay
it's like a non-stop horror show
everywhere you look just bad after bad
after bad God knows what I've done and
he forces my eyes on it when I'm weak
and when I'm scared it was not my fault
but Judah could not swim nor the lust he
felt for me I would have saved him had
either strength I do not value God but
please spare me the suffering such horse
dreams even when I do not sleep I cannot
keep watching him drown accept my death
is penance as I am newly heavy with
popping off his child and wracked with
pain such as I have never known surely
the infant in my womb must be the arch
theme for the affliction of nightmares
and Agony's that fill and surround me I
am yours okay could pop enough stop just
straight up raping everybody in the town
that does that what the first thing that
I would like in the new world order here
and then just everybody just kind of
stop - - stop good because you know you
just feel a little oh all of its too
cool
all right well carrying on whatever else
is hell-hole holds in store for us
hello oh boy oh boy oh boy oh no not oh
[ __ ] you guys
oh [ __ ] you guys oh [ __ ] you guys [ __ ]
you rattles oh god damn it what is this
the [ __ ] Garbo
he's upstairs thanks deuce oh boy okay
we're going I'm jumping over I'm jumping
over I'll my ankle bone okay were my
going where am I going I don't even know
anymore I connect I shut the [ __ ] up for
one second oh oh no supposed to be a six
line but it didn't work that way
god damn it these guys are persistent I
mean I get to make sense the whole town
is looking for me and I guess they
wouldn't give up that easily it's kind
of a non-stop adrenaline rush oh boy
okay you missed me [ __ ]
ah-ha dig hole alright so I just got to
get through here and then I got to keep
running I think it's a cornfield nearby
maybe maybe maybe I can lose them in the
cornfield Oh gonna jump for it
cool boy hell yeah I'm gonna open for it
oh okay alright let's do this again
hey okay good idea no don't go up Ellie
oh boy okay alright keep going then pop
alright
they're gonna man they're just tearing
it up [ __ ] dude give it up not worth it
how do I get in here good
mine under vent I know nothing I don't
know the red I don't know the bed okay I
think that's a good place to in this
video that was insanity and yet we made
it through somehow with a few stars on
us but we made it through nonetheless so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know how i'm doing the comments
below and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]